un 5 4 3 2 1
[Musique]
depuis la libération en 1945
les démineurs de la sécurité civile
nettoie le sol français des millions de
munitions non explosées issus des deux
grandes guerres dans les années 70 leur
opération se multiplier les explosifs
récupérés sont rassemblés et disposés en
fourneaux jeux les plus petits 2 choux
les plus gros pardessus chaque fourneaux
peut ainsi contenir 10 tonnes d'engins
avec les militaires les démineurs de la
sécurité civile font partie des
professionnels habilités à manipuler et
à désamorcer ces explosifs des
opérations réalisées au péril de leur
vie de nos camarades de nos amis sont
morts à cette tâche 594 depuis la
libération
cet énorme des risques qui n'arrêtait
pourtant passé des mineurs en 1974 les
engins qu'on ramasse c'est d'autant plus
étrange est que nous on neutralise que
les enfants ne peuvent pas jouer avec
nous qu'il n'y a pas de chin enfants ni
rien mais certaines bombes échappe
parfois la vigilance des artificiers
trouvés au hasard d'une balade ou objets
de collection ses armes de guerre
suscite la curiosité
au prix parfois de drame exemple ici en
c'est sous ce tas de bois que les
enfants ont découvert l'engin
le père de l'un d'eux l'avait cachée
dans un sac en plastique
c'est en le soulevant vraisemblablement
que l'ade des enfants l'a laissé tomber
l'engin a explosé aussitôt valentin et
caroline eric allain et alex et art
seront enterrés demain
dans les années quatre-vingt six cent
soixante mille bombes 13,5 millions de
mines et 24 millions d'obus et autres
explosifs avaient été dégagés par les
démineurs français depuis 1945
aujourd'hui les désamorçage de bombes
sont encore fréquents en france les
opérations qui nécessitent parfois
l'évacuation de la population dans les
rues du village
les gendarmes font du porte à porte pour
s'assurer que les maisons sont vides
avant le début des opérations de
déminage
plus de soixante dix ans après la
libération de nombreuses munitions non
explosées sont encore présentes dans le
sol français
selon l'association des mines ex il
faudra encore sept siècles de déminage
pour en venir à bout
[Musique]